[Música]
o
vamos à noite pessoal meu nome é cláudia
nogueira
eu tô aqui pra conversar com vocês um
pouquinho hoje sobre o trabalho que a
gente vem fazendo aqui em belém com
crianças com transtorno do espectro do
autismo com distúrbios de aprendizagem
com problemas de comportamento
mas antes de eu chegar lá eu queria
contar um pouquinho pra vocês da minha
trajetória e de como eu cheguei onde
cheguei
na verdade eu escolhi e queria fazer
psicologia desde muito cedo
eu me lembro que mais ou menos aos 16
anos de idade
eu falei para o meu pai que eu ia fazer
psicologia para trabalhar com pessoas
com necessidades educacionais especiais
ele não entendeu muito bem a gente não
tem ninguém na família com transtorno do
espectro do autismo pessoas com
necessidades educacionais especiais
meu pai é muito que eu fizesse medicina
e ele imbuído da necessidade de me
questionar arrumou uma visita pra mim
uma escola de educação especial lan em
minas no interior de minas onde a gente
vivia eu tô isso há trinta anos atrás
fui para a escola passar o dia lá amei
amei adorei está com as crianças adorei
estar ali me senti super à vontade
voltei pra casa feliz meu pai me
esperando no portão e aí filha e eu
sensacional é isso que eu quero fazer
tenho certeza não tinha mais o que falar
tudo bem
escolhe o que você realmente gosta vá em
frente desde que você esteja disposta a
realmente estudar e se empenhar a fazer
muito bem o que você quer fazer o que cê
tá metendo em encrenca
fiz faculdade me formei em psicologia e
sem as coisas acontecem na vida da gente
sem que a gente prepare muito sem muito
esperar a verdade é que eu conheci uma
pessoa me casei e ele foi transferido
para fora do brasil
saí do brasil eu já havia começado a
trabalhar aqui na época estava tratando
com crianças com paralisia cerebral
muito feliz com o que eu estava fazendo
sair do brasil pensando poxa ela ainda
mais oportunidade de fazer o que eu
gosto
engano meu sair do brasil e lá fora não
era psicóloga
eu não era reconhecida pelo que eu havia
me preparado para fazer aqui e ficou
muito claro pra mim que se eu quisesse
continuar fazendo o que eu fazia eu
teria que estudar
estudei muito inicialmente no que seria
um centro de educação para adultos eu
precisava aprender inglês
aprendi inglês continua estudando
vivi 20 anos fora do brasil e teve sete
filhos é mudei por vários países ea
história minha mesmo com o autismo não
começa até 2008 quando depois de ter
andado por vários países nós fomos
transferidos de volta para os estados
unidos
e eu fui morar numa cidade onde eu sabia
que existia um programa de certificação
em análise do comportamento
eu fui procurar esse programa não porque
eu queria estudar análise de
comportamento mas eu queria estudar na
comportamento porque eu sabia já que
essa era uma ciência e uma abordagem que
estava sendo reconhecida que estava que
tinha muita evidência mostrando os
resultados no trabalho com pessoas com
necessidades educacionais especiais
lá dentro eu comecei a aprender sobre
autismo
eu não sei se vocês convivem se vocês
conhecem alguém com autismo mas quando
eu iniciei a minha carreira na
psicologia me diziam é importante saber
sobre autismo mas provavelmente não vai
encontrar ninguém com autismo na tua
carreira existe uma incidência de 1 para
cada mil pessoas
não sei se vocês sabem hoje a incidência
de autismo é de um para cada 68 pessoas
a gente conhece muito pouca gente que
não tem que nunca ouviu falar que não
convive com alguém que esteja no
transtorno do espectro do autismo
eu aprendi então que as pessoas com
autismo apresentam as diferenças
comportamentais que elas apresentam
muito cedo nos primeiros anos de vida
essas são evidentes e são diferenças na
com 11 social e diferenças em
comportamento e interesses
comportamentos repetitivos interesses
restritos diferenças na comunicação
social gente a gente tem crianças já
muito pequenininhas com menos de 3 anos
de idade onde fica muito evidente que
não só essa criança tem um atraso de
fala mas também um atraso na intenção
comunicativa essa criança não aprende a
dar tchauzinho a jogar beijinho a bater
palma a pedir apontando o que ela quer a
usar um brinquedo e mostrar
a surpresa dela quando aquele
brinquedinho faz pão
essa criança que brinca que pega um
brinquedo e brinca de uma maneira suas
geniais que pega o brinquedo e fica
repetindo coisas com aquele brin
esses são alguns indícios de um
desenvolvimento atípico
aprendi isso durante o meu curso de
certificação aprendi também que se a
gente quer mudar a qualidade de vida
dessas pessoas que estão apresentando
sinais do transtorno do espectro do
autismo
a intervenção ela precisa ser intensiva
ela precisa ser abrangente e ela precisa
ser muito precoce e por intervenção
precoce
a gente está falando de intervenção que
começa antes dos três anos de idade por
intervenção intensiva o modelo propõe
que ela deve ser feita 20 e 40 horas por
dia e por intervenção abrangente
a gente quer dizer que ela precisa
abordar aspectos do desenvolvimento
motor da fala do desenvolvimento social
de habilidades pedagógicas do brincar
dessa criança de atenção conjunta de
atividades de vida diária ou seja todos
os aspectos de desenvolvimento da
criança como é que a gente vai oferecer
esses serviços
e como é que isso vai ser feito aqui no
brasil existe um modelo existe um modelo
lá fora eu tive o privilégio a
oportunidade de ver esse modelo
funcionando e eu realmente me comprometi
com desenvolver serviços para pessoas
com autismo
quando na verdade eu comecei a minha
prática e eu conheci as crianças que
vocês estão vendo ali eu comecei sendo
atendente terapêutica na casa dessas
crianças e esses foram os meus primeiros
pacientes e um atendente terapêutico é
alguém que vai pra casa das crianças
trabalha com ela
três quatro horas por dia
eu conheci cada uma das crianças tem uma
faltando aí é que me ensinou a carregar
ela nas costas até quando se vocês
vissem serviriam que ela já estava quase
do meu tamanho
mas gostava tanto a gente se divertia
tanto fazendo isso que essa era uma
rotina diária
eu conheci esse grupo de crianças
loirinhas que são dos irmãos todos com
transtorno do espectro do autismo e que
me ensinaram muito os pequenininhos os
menores índices eu conheci com menos de
3 anos de idade
o menorzinho deles eu conheci antes de
um ano de idade
os outros já estavam maior zinhos o
rapazinho que vocês vêem há de bom ele
não tá ela que vocês vêem com tablet
aprendeu a falar os sete anos de idade e
master sabia ler desde os 5
essas crianças me ensinaram muito muito
muito e elas me ensinaram mais que tudo
é que por mais que eu tivesse estudado
por mais que eu achasse que eu sabia
sobre autismo eu só ia conseguir
ensiná-las se eu aprendesse com elas
se eu permitir se que eles me mostrassem
o caminho
eu também conhece os pais dessas
crianças
passei muitas horas conversando com as
mães dessas crianças fundos há muitas
consultas médicas fomos a a escola
conversar sobre o plano de educação
dessas crianças
eu tive a oportunidade de ver de perto o
dia a dia dessas famílias
e aí mais uma vez sem que eu planejar se
a vida me trouxe de volta ao brasil
depois de 20 anos fora eu voltei para o
brasil e claro já muito envolvida com o
trabalho que eu fazia
fui procurar de novo que eu sabia
procurar qual a instituição de ensino o
que é que se existe no país
em relação à intervenção aqui em belém
a gente tem a sorte de ter na
universidade federal do pará um programa
chamado aprende onde se faz pesquisa e
intervenção com crianças com autismo e
onde a gente tem pessoas muito muito
comprometidas com o ensino de pessoas
com tela
lá eu conheci duas pessoas maravilhosas
que compartilham da mesma visão que eu
compartilho a gente montou um centro de
intervenção que a link onde a gente
assim mas que nada a gente tem essa
crença em comum de que todo mundo pode
aprender desde que a gente saiba ensinar
nem todo mundo aprende do mesmo jeito
mas nós todos aprendemos a gente tem lá
na linha de crianças de 1 aninho de
idade
eu tenho criança que chegou lá com de
meses de idade até crianças maiores
linhas ea ideia é criar um programa que
os prepare pra escola que os prepare
para a comunidade que os prepare para
brincar com os amigos que o que eles
consigam aprender ali eles possam levar
para fora
agora eu falei antes esse programa ele
tem que ser abrangente esse programa tem
que ser intensivo
a gente conta com uma equipe de
pedagogos psicólogos terapeutas
ocupacionais
a gente cria um ambiente de ensino que
propicie esse aprendizado esse ambiente
dizendo tem necessariamente que ser um
ambiente de ensino muito acolhedor e
muito divertido
é um centro que parece uma um híbrido
entre uma clínica e uma escolinha tem
popular tem tem tem brinquedo em tem e
tem mesinha e tenta e as crianças passam
ali conosco em média dois a cinco dias
por semana três horas diárias
elas vão geralmente no contraturno da
escola e ficam ali conosco eu ainda sei
que mesmo fazendo isso a matemática não
fecha duas vezes por semana três horas a
gente tem seis horas de intervenção para
que a gente consiga realmente fazer uma
mudança efetiva na vida dessas crianças
eu preciso dos pais dessas crianças que
os cuidadores dessas crianças e os
professores dessas crianças é também
participem dessa intervenção e
normalmente não somos só nós essa
criança também tem fono tem teor tem uma
equipe que trabalha junto com ela
é um trabalho minucioso é um trabalho de
dia a dia e é um trabalho que conta
necessariamente com um grupo muito
grande de pessoas
agora eu escolhi fazer isso eu adoro
quando uma criança me desafia e eu
preciso olhar uma nova maneira de
aprender para poder ensinar essa criança
elas se divertem
eu aprendo com elas eu adoro os beijos
que eu ganho as risadas que a gente dá
junto acho que hoje eu não conseguiria
viver sem os pezinhos que passam por ali
é correndo mas essas crianças cada uma
delas é tem também pais pais que não
necessariamente sonharam com isso ou
escolheram tá ali comigo pais que chegam
conosco na maioria das vezes
no momento do diagnóstico
no momento que muda a vida dessas
famílias e paz que vem me buscar e que
por mais que eu faça um exercício de
empatia eu sei que eu não sei o que eles
estão passando é não posso nem nem
sonhar com que eles estão passando
e aí quando eles chegam até mim tudo que
eu posso oferecer pra eles é que eu
gostaria de caminhar ao lado deles
eu não tenho a pretensão de dizer pra
esses pais que eu sei onde é que a gente
vai estar
dali a dois anos onde é que a gente vai
estar ea cinco anos
eu sei que a gente vai estar muito
melhor de um do que quando a gente está
naquele momento em que a gente inicia eu
sei sim que essa intervenção nesse
modelo pode absolutamente mudar a vida
dessa criança a gente vive isso cada dia
e cada vez que um paisinho de se me
permite que eu faça essa caminhada do
lado deles e cada vez que a gente escuta
um muito obrigado que a gente vê uma
criança aprendendo que a gente vê uma
criança falar pra amanhã assim por
exemplo na não tem atendimento hoje mas
eu quero ir pra link porque eu quero
brincar é a glória é tudo que eu posso
querer
mas ainda assim eu sou extrema
extremamente grata pelo fato pela pelo
desafio que essas crianças me apresentam
pelo fato delas me ensinarem a buscar a
motivação delas pra aprenderem a cada
dia estou também muito muito grata aos
pais que me permitem fazer a caminhada
ao lado deles
ando me permitem eu queria que eles
todos soubessem que é uma honra
obrigado